♪
>>> THAT'S GENE KELLY AND FRANK
SINATRA SINGING THE PRAISES OF
AMERICA'S LARGEST CITY IN A 1949
MUSICAL.
♪
TO THEM IT WAS A WONDERFUL TOWN.
BUT IT'S ALSO KNOWN AS GOTHAM.
THE CITY THAT NEVER SLEEPS.
AND PERHAPS MOST FAMOUSLY, THE
BIG APPLE.
AND THIS PAST WEEK, THAT MONIKER
CELEBRATED ITS 100th
ANNIVERSARY.
THE TERM FIRST APPEARED IN A
RACING COLUMN IN THE MAY 3rd,
1921 EEDITION OF THE NOW-DEFUNCT
"NEW YORK MORNING TELEGRAPH."
LILLY TUTTLE IS A CURATOR AT THE
MUSEUM OF THE CITY OF NEW YORK.
>> SO THE TERM THE BIG APPLE
CAME ABOUT FROM A SPORTS
JOURNALIST NAMED JOHN J.
FITZGERALD.
HE HAD OVERHEARD TWO
AFRICAN-AMERICAN STABLE HANDS
USE THE TERM TO DESCRIBE THE
WORLD OF HORSE RACING IN NEW
YORK CITY.
AND HE WAS APPARENTLY CAPTIVATED
BY THIS TERMINOLOGY AND USED IT
IN HIS STORY.
>> IN THE 1930s, JAZZ PERFORMERS
STARTED USING THE TERM.
>> I WANT TO SHOW THAT GAL THE
BIG APPLE --
>> WELL, ALL RIGHT.
LET'S SWING IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT.
>> IN 1937 IT BECAME A DANCE
CRAZE.
♪
SOON EVERYBODY WAS DOING THE BIG
APPLE.
THE TERM THEN FELL INTO
OBSCURITY UNTIL THE 1970s.
NEW YORK WAS GOING THROUGH A
ROUGH TIME WITH HIGH CRIME RATES
AND A LOOMING FINANCIAL CRISIS.
CHARLES GILLETT, THEN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE NEW YORK
CONVENTION AND VISITORS BUREAU,
RECALLED THE TERM FROM THAT
EARLIER ERA.
HE USED IT AS THE CENTERPIECE OF
A PR CAMPAIGN TO HELP REVERSE
THE CITY'S ROTTING IMAGE.
♪
♪ I LOVE NEW YORK ♪
>> NOW THE BIG APPLE IS SEEN AND
HEARD EVERYWHERE IN NEW YORK.
♪
FROM PARADES --
>> HE SMACKS ONE TO DEEP LEFT
FIELD --
>> TO SPORTS ARENAS.
>> THERE GOES THE APPLE --
>> AND EVEN THE BIG TOP.
♪
>> SO WHEN YOU KIND OF THINK
ABOUT NEW YORK AS LIKE IF IT
WERE A FRUIT, IT WOULD BE A
FRUIT THAT HAS A REALLY BRIGHT,
BOLD COLOR AND SOMETHING YOU CAN
REALLY KIND OF SINK YOUR TEETH
INTO WHICH FEELS PRETTY
APPROPRIATE FOR NEW YORK CITY.
♪
>> INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH, IT WAS
ALSO CALLED THE NEW ORANGE BACK
IN THE 1600s AFTER WILLIAM III
OF THE ORANGES -- WE STILL DON'T
KNOW WHY.
THAT'S THE BIG QUESTION.
THE -- DON'T KNOW WH